remote work has made people lazy the average hours
worked per day has dropped from 8.2 hours per day
in 2019 to just 5.7 hours per day in 2023 in other
words remote hybrid workers which now encompasses
a third of all Americans work less than 30 hours
per week on average and it's no wonder why some
companies like Tesla and apple are adamant that
people return to the office but most companies
and even the government are just rolling with it
take Google for example back in 2021 they had all
this press about returning to the office but just
last month they basically officially gave up on
this effort by putting 1.4 million square feet
worth of office space up for a sublease but why
are companies putting up with this clearly people
tend to work less from home well though people do
tend to work less total hours they actually
tend to be more productive they don't have to
worry about spending an hour on commuting each
way or packing lunch or buying lunch or waking
up super early or any of the other cons that
come with in-person work they're able to focus
on just work itself making them more efficient
and productive for the hours that they do work
in fact it's estimated that the modern hybrid
economy is five percent more productive than
the traditional in-person economy as such some
companies are even taking this to the next level
by experimenting with four day work weeks and even
20 hour work weeks the idea is that while people
work substantially as ours overall productivity
shouldn't change all that much this brings up the
question are 30 hour and 20 hour work weeks the
future of office jobs well I believe the answer
is absolutely in fact I think it's just a matter
of time until a big tech company experiments with
such a schedule officially you see smaller work
weeks don't just work from a logical perspective
but from a cynical perspective as well so
join me as we take a look at how smaller
work weeks will not only make tech companies more
productive but infinitely more profitable foreign
for starters working 8 hours a day is complete BS
for most office workers most of the time they're
just waiting on someone else sitting in useless
meetings or just working slowly in fact during
an eight hour work day the average worker only
spends 4 hours and 12 minutes actually doing
work the rest of the day is spent on surfing the
internet social media texting bathroom breaks and
socializing with co-workers now of course before
you get mad in the comments let me acknowledge
that this isn't true for all jobs especially those
that require manual labor if you're a mechanic or
a truck driver or a plumber this is obviously
not the case not only can these people work a
full eight hours a day but they can actually be
more or less productive the entire time the Sim
however cannot be said about office workers
in fact Studies have found that even the most
productive office workers are only able to be
productive for six hours per day in other words
even the most productive office workers waste two
hours every single day so really there's no reason
for work weeks to be longer than 30 hours per
week and remote work is proving exactly this when
people work from home they definitely have more
distractions they might be taking care of their
children or working on a house project or cooking
or whatever else but despite this remote workers
are far more productive because they tend to
approach work in a completely different light when
you're forced to be at work for eight hours you
can actually tend to work slower because there's
no benefit to working faster you have to be there
for all eight hours even if you finish within four
or five hours so people tend to stretch out the
work throughout the entire day also when people
are in person they feel less of a need to prove
themselves to their managers and bosses their
presence itself goes a long way in showing that
they're committed and working hard when they're
working from home however it's a whole other ball
game suddenly employees are judged solely on their
output as opposed to their presence I mean let's
be honest everyone knows that you can just have
teams open and move them hours every 10 minutes
so no manager really takes online hours all that
seriously it's all about progress and work output
as such employees also tend to focus on hitting a
certain Milestone or getting something done
within a workday as opposed to working an
arbitrary number of hours it's actually kind of
a motivating factor if they can just focus on
getting X item done they can just be done for
the entire day so they're incentivized to work
harder and more efficiently during the hours that
they do work also given that they now have more
downtime employees are in a much better state of
mind they're more relaxed less stressed and just
happier in general in fact one study found that
remote work increases employee Happiness by 20
which of course leads to more productivity not to
mention it with remote and hybrid work companies
are able to get away with less office space less
corporate food less electricity less internet
basically less of everything so it's really a
win-win scenario for companies happier employees
less costs and more productivity and if you don't
believe me just take it from history foreign
work weeks themselves are actually a super new
invention in fact they haven't even been around
for a hundred years yet 40 hour work weeks didn't
even become a lot till 1940 when the fair labor
standards Act was amended before this Factory
workers would generally work 12 to 16 hours a day
for six days a week their only off day was Sunday
so that they could go to church this meant that
the average employee was generally working about
a hundred hours every single week of course there
were activists in the labor unions who were trying
to bring this down for decades but nothing really
changed until Henry Ford stepped in in 1926 Ford
would become the first major company to implement
a 40-hour work week they were essentially cutting
down working hours by over half but they kept the
pay the same this was an insane development Ford
was already a top paying company similar to Tech
companies today in fact Ford was already paying
nearly two times the average Factory salary for
both men and women and now they were gonna cut
down working hours by 60 I mean this was ludicrous
surely their productivity would plummet given how
labor-intensive building cars is but this didn't
happen in fact the exact opposite happened Ford
was already a desirable place to work but this
made Ford the place to be for the working class
the amount of pride and loyalty that Ford saw
from their Factory workers was unprecedented and
though they were only working eight hours a day
for its productivity per hour was higher than ever
but despite this massive success other companies
were obviously hesitant in implementing a similar
work schedule the argument was oh it may work for
Ford but it wouldn't work for us but over time
They too had to make it work not because of laws
or strikes or protests or any of that but simply
because of supply and demand for obvious reasons
all of the best welders and Painters and designers
and inspectors walked over to Ford and the other
companies that were offering such perks the only
people left at companies like GM who were on blank
reduced hours were people who literally had no
other choice this meant that employee morale
and thus productivity fell lava Cliff at these
companies so they really had no choice but to
follow suit now nearly a hundred years later were
met with a similar set of Crossroads remote work
has made it clear that 40 hour work weeks are very
much outdated and this is really not surprising
thanks to automation Tech and now ai much of the
things that humans work on aren't exactly effort
dependent rather they're creativity dependent
which is a limited resource just because a ux
engineer at Google works longer doesn't mean
that the UI will actually turn out to be more
visually pleasing or intuitive of course this
logic is most applicable for tech companies and
that's why they'd be the ones leading the
way similar to Ford so while a reduction
from 40 hours down to 30 hours or even 20
hours may seem crazy at first glance it's
really not we saw a much greater decrease just
a hundred years ago and that was definitely for
the better moreover there is a much more cynical
reason for reducing working hours anyway foreign
even on the surface there's obviously a lot
of cynical benefits to reducing working hours
companies like Google and Facebook can easily
improve their brand image without sacrificing
on productivity or progress similarly they can
reduce operating expenses by spending Less on
Office Buildings but all of that is just
a bonus there is a much darker reason to
produce working hours that Henry Ford was well
aware of by substantially increasing wages and
decreasing working hours Ford ensured that
his employees not only had time to enjoy the
benefits of a car but also the money to afford
a car before this only the royalty could afford
cars with substantially limited Ford's reach but
by making this pivot Ford was not only able to
make cars affordable for his own employees but
the entirety of the working class across America
fun fact cars were more affordable for low-level
Factory workers at Ford 100 years ago than they
are for the average American today Ford was
paying a minimum wage of five dollars per day
which meant that it would take a Ford employee
at most 11 weeks to afford a 260 Model T today
the median income in the US is forty four thousand
dollars but to even a four day base level Toyota
Corolla it would take 26 weeks of income no wonder
cars became so popular but anyway tech companies
today are in the perfect position to do the exact
same thing but with tech these companies are very
much the Ford of the 21st century they have the
most power control and influence so you can bet
that if they reduce working hours other companies
will be forced to follow along not just within the
us but internationally sure work hours May not
drop all the way to 20 hours across the world
for countries that tend to work more hours may
drop from 100 to 80 or 80 to 70. given that most
tech companies operate off of free product they
don't even need people to have more money they
just need people to have more time in an Ideal
World a 20-hour work week would mean that people
spend more time with family and friends and on
trips and relaxation and all of that but you can
bet that if a 20-hour work week were to actually
be implemented most people would just spend more
time on their phones than social media and guess
who owns these platforms it's of course the tech
companies right now the average person only spends
2 hours and 31 minutes per day on social media but
with the 20-hour work weeks this could easily
go up to four or five hours per day which would
essentially double the income of these platforms
so it really doesn't even matter if shorter work
weeks marginally affect the productivity of
these companies they'd essentially be trading
10 or 20 less productivity from their 100 or
200 000 employees in return for hours of time
from billions of people and the best part is
that they'll look like they're good guys who
are on the employee side and it's really a 200
IQ move as Henry Ford declared every man needs
more than one day a week for rest and Recreation I
mean to buy Model T cars similarly tech companies
can declare every person needs more than 16
hours a day for rest and record I mean to use
our platforms as much as possible as this is
the real reason that companies will push for
shorter and shorter work weeks and embrace
remote work simply it makes more business
sense something else that's counter-intuitively
more profitable is giving up profitability check
out this video to learn more but until then
I'm Hari I'll see you guys on the next one